how much of um Sports media is like
because because you will always see like
uh unspoken beefs with people like I've
seen I've seen Michelle Beadle say stuff
about Rachel Nichols and obviously
there's like yeah I think it was on a
podcast or something okay
um as I call her mama mama bees don't
play she don't give a damn goddamn Spurs
fan too God bless him
um but how much of it is like is there
like a lot of stuff that we don't get to
see where people really just don't [__]
with each other but they have to be on
TV with each other oh absolutely because
we've seen so much of that recently
where like
Skip and Shannon had big big blowouts or
or uh perk and uh JJ Redick or you know
there's been all these things where
you're like oh
gets a lot of eyes and it feels a lot
more authentic than a lot of stuff we've
seen but it does seem like there's a lot
of unspoken
tension yeah in the industry that's part
of the disruption that's part of what's
leading Us in the Groundswell to go to
more Independence because both of those
scenarios has an independent Creator
content creator kind of mixed up in
there so you got Skip and Shannon all
right they've been doing this show for
seven years why y'all beefing now
independent creation which gave him the
different Lane of popularity whether you
say it's to the same level or surpass
and Skip that's something skip can't
compete with right skip has his own
podcast no one watches I can't say no
one could you got more subscribers than
me but he been around way longer than me
I'm gonna catch him real quick real
quick yeah you have great numbers for
six months dude sure it's it's going and
I'm loving it so there's a there's a
club Shay there's also a Kwame Brown
element of like stirring it up he's a
wild boy that Kwame Brown man oh funny
hilarious well stare look at you and
stir it up and then say now what you
gonna do I'm on my tractor here good
luck so anyway I'm just trying to get
people the Dynamics of why these things
are shifting same thing when you talk
about a situation where there's a
Stephen A and then there's a Max
Kellerman and you see that situation
you're like what's going on well because
the internet has such a loud voice so
when you're trying to protect your brand
you're almost in a reality show now
people got it twisted during the reality
show ain't hard it's when it's edited
and it's when the world gets to see it
and respond and talk about you that's
when it gets hard so skip Shannon
Stephen A Max oh we fine doing this it's
just when we go home and check oh this
is subconsciously [__] gets to you
sometimes I'm sure yeah I'm gonna sell
out oh I'm dumb oh he Cooler Than Me
Like You know I mean and then all sudden
you start to weave and and do things a
little differently what's your
prediction for Shannon Sharp
wrong let me say that uh
uh before you answer yeah I think if I'm
him what I hope let me tell you what I
hope I hope he just goes all in on
himself okay what does that mean though
I think he takes Club shayshay to a
daily he obviously does the inner but I
think if he did okay if he did a Daily
Show on his own channel
and he did that for a year two years and
built up leverage whatever bag he's
about to get would be way bigger because
he's got all the attention and all the
eyes on him right now that's what I
would do what do you think is going to
happen yeah like if I could and I think
the magic wand would be exactly what
McAfee did like he literally would turn
shayshay into it daily and he could let
it be on ESPN
um because there were talks of Shay
Shake being on Fox in the summer during
the the door right right now yeah
um you would let it live every single
day pour all the resources into it then
you would have like also the commercial
being on first take or something your
ESPN Club Shay Shays every day then I
chime in here and there once a week with
Stephen A because that's the biggest
Daily Show they had all right well
you're gonna have number one Daily Show
and maybe number two with Club Shay Shay
or flip that order maybe yeah you never
know while still keeping your
Independence because you're licensing it
right so it's basically what the McAfee
model is how do you think he's gonna do
though
snap you just don't see him going back
to Fox I see him doing the once a day
once a week with First Take Stephen A
maybe Mondays during the football season
yep I see him ramping up Club Shay but
not daily on YouTube and continuing to
leverage that I see him leaning into his
cognac
um and slang and that and I also see
him trying to build it up to a point
where
he's not
in the space he is right now which is
once a week he lateral move or promotion
would be another because you would think
like if you see the amount of money that
DraftKings gave Pat if you're saying or
FanDuel I'm sorry no if you uh if you're
Shannon sharp you got to be like
I'm more popular maybe maybe it's close
well not close in subscribers no no no
not any subscribers I just mean in terms
of like star power oh right now Shannon
sharp and everybody's talking about
Shannon sharp as they should he's
popping right now okay my agent my uh
broadcasting podcast agent I have two
but one of them
was just working on a nine figure deal
now I can't say who because he didn't
tell me who but I kind of narrowed the
borders I was like yeah and I know I
think one of them could be Shannon the
other I'm not gonna say it I got to
protect the guilty because the guy
doesn't want it out it could be still
Shannon or somebody else but long story
short the money's out there dog nine
figures nine figures so you know that's
the old McAfee FanDuel kind of deal so
it could be Shannon but the point is I
don't see him having a Daily Show on
ESPN unless this club Shay Shay I would
love to see that and then let them do
first take once a week
call that a rap leverage it for a couple
years and then see what's next what's
the next Frontier who is somebody who
helped you the most in growing as a
broadcaster over the years obviously
transitioning from playing in the NFL
for 10 years coming to TV was there like
a big homie of yours that like really
kind of helped show you the ropes yeah
day one no lie I left the football field
and I didn't know how big Mike and Mike
was I knew how big ESPN was but when
you're playing I swear people think
you're lying
I didn't watch any of them shows I
didn't know they even had daily shows I
didn't know they had NFL live I think I
believe you back then I feel like
nowadays this whole heart it's very hard
to avoid it okay but yeah but back then
I get it yeah no I never heard of Mikey
Mike right I never heard of NFL live
um it was just so Random right I knew
about NFL prime time and I knew like why
Sports Center and Burman right Chris
Berman and yeah Jackson right right I
mean um uh what's my man I can't think
God Lee I'm bad I can't think of this
guy he played for the Broncos yes [__]
what's that God Lee y'all gonna kill me
in the comments Do It um but yeah those
guys and I was like that was a I have
made it if I made a highlight on there
right right so I'm looking around I'm
like all right I'm at ESPN day one and
they're like all right can you get up at
like five in the morning be in the
studio 5 15 and once you're on Mike and
Mike I was like all right radio show and
I was like damn radio like I can't take
this later I'm like not even slighting
them in my head I'm like right I gotta
do a fight but this is my opportunity so
I'm gonna do this show called Mike and
Mike and I get there and it's Mike
Greenberg Mike Golic I just feel in for
a segment you know do a little guess
appearance I'm out and I'll say I got up
at five o'clock just for one segment and
then when I was done I was like I could
see this is bigger than I thought but
yeah
got off air check my phone and it was
lit up like I signed a new deal wow I
was like God dang I was like Mikey Mike
that they're in every city everywhere
for however many years it was like the
longest Morning Show I mean I just
remember my whole life Mike and Mike was
on it feels like
um
so which so which mic helped you out the
most Golic Golic now after that first
segment yeah
he literally comes to me and he's like
dude you're a Storyteller he's like
don't ever let somebody tell you any
different he's like everyone can do this
x's and no stuff there's computers for
that Etc he's like your stories please
just stick to your stories don't script
out your takes don't be rigid don't get
on that railroad track just tell stories
your experiences are insane to the point
where the next week they called me to
come in it was to fill in for Mike
Greenberg who was going and I literally
did a four hour show on Mike and Mike
that's my second week from being just
from being like one segment early in the
morning crazy and I just ran with it I
never got boxed in to the purest version
of broadcasting which is X's and O's
third and goal what should they do or
they should play actually I I was like
dog I'm talking about the girls talking
about the club I'm talking about the
player talking about his life talking
about his emotions I'm I'm doing the
eyes and U's not the X's and O's and I
just kept going with that because I got
that kind Confidence from Golic when I
first got there